Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today, we have a new episode of Clustered,
and we have teams edition.
We have two great teams, one from Polar
Signals and one from Pulumi.
Going to be a great episode, if not
at least interesting,
and I'll fill you in on why
in just a moment. Now before we get
into that, I wanna say thank you to
Teleport. Teleport sponsor Clustered. We've been using Teleport
since the very first episode. We use it
weekend. Week out is such an amazing tool
that I generally believe every
every infrastructure, every production infrastructure at least should
have Teleport running. You'll see why as we
debug our clusters and pay it all of
them as a great piece of software.
I also wanna say thank you to Equinix
Medal, and they graciously provide all of the
hardware that we use in custard. We we
burn through a lot of bare metal machines
and just for the fun, I always use
ones with lots of cores and lots of
RAM. But I really appreciate that. It makes
it just a little bit more fun for
me and for the other contestants.
Thank you to Equinix Medal.
Alright. Now let's introduce team
Polar signals. Hey. How's it going, everyone?
Good. Good. And you?
Yeah. Just you know, I really wish I
would learn not to throw a very generic
question at three people at once and then
see who answers first. But Yeah.
Let's let's start at the top right. Frederic,
do you wanna introduce yourself? And then we'll
just work our way around clockwise, please. Sounds
good. Alright. Hey. I'm Frederick. I'm the founder
of Polar Signals.
I've been
working on all things, like, cloud native
for, gosh,
six, seven years now. I'm part part of
the Prometheus team. I until recently was tech
lead for special
interest group for instrumentation in Kubernetes.
Yeah.
I started my journey in through the through
CoreOS,
then
Chorus was was acquired by Red Hat and
stuck around for a little bit. And then,
eventually, I I left Red Hat and started
pulling signals.
Awesome. Thank you.
Kemal?
Oh, alright. Hey. Hey. My name is Kemal.
I'm a senior software engineer in Polar Signals.
I don't know what else to say. Yeah.
I've been working with these guys for the
past
few years.
So yeah. Thank
you.
Hi. I'm Matthias Leuve.
I'm based in Berlin.
And, yeah, I work with as
well, obviously, and been doing
I don't know. Like, I think I started
Go development in 2014,
and then through that came interested in Docker
and then
in into Drone and then kind of, like,
read about Kubernetes.
So here we are. Looked for a job
for Kubernetes and ended up finding one in
Berlin
where where, like, on the first day, I
got introduced to Prometheus.
So that was in 2016.
And, yeah, like, May later, Prometheus maintainer,
Thanos maintainer,
and, yeah, been enjoying working in observability
ever since. It's been a great journey.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you all. Alright. I guess
we'll fill the audience in on the fun
things now that's happening on this episode of
Clustered.
So this episode was originally scheduled to be
Polar Signals and Isovalent. Unfortunately, team Isovalent had
something come up, and we had to replace
them very last minute. And I very luckily
was able to convince a few of my
colleagues at Bolivia to join us. So I
have smashed through a cluster that you're gonna
work through today.
Hopefully, it's not too smashed.
Although, I guess that would be fair considering
the cluster that I prepare used prepared for
us is currently
gone. It
is not responding at all, which obviously cannot
be fixed. However, we are spinning up a
quick backup, and then hopefully we'll have something
to debug in forty minutes time. Fingers crossed.
So it's been quite an episode already, but
that's the way things go on clustered.
When you break things intentionally, things do go
wrong. So I'm gonna wish you all the
best of luck with the cluster that we
have prepared,
and I'm gonna pop open my screen share
now.
So first thing I need to do is
give you access. So I am gonna modify
your role.
Label. That's so cool. I didn't even realize
we hadn't hacked have access.
So
Yeah. I'm not gonna give you access to
all the machines. But now if you refresh
your page, you will see
almost mine. My teleport
control plane is hidden. But you will be
able to see my session on Pulumi control
plane one, which is here.
And so if you could all please join
this session, give me an echo hello, let
me know that you're there and we'll take
it away. In fact, while away,
I can tell you that you also have
another cluster. So
at some point over the next thirty minutes,
if one of you could reapply the break
cluster too, that would be appreciated.
If I just trust it doesn't disappear.
Yep. I I I take care of it.
I broke it half
an hour an hour ago.
I I tried to not break it as
much again.
So, yeah, I I I take care of
that.
Well, maybe we'll get lucky in, like, cluster
one, and we'll just magically show back up
again. But let's just be prepared anyway.
So I've got Frederick in this session.
I need two more.
Alright. Awesome. Cool.
And Matthias, I know that you're working on
the other one. You're here anyway. Cool.
Alright.
Usually, on custard, your best bet is to
check for a control plan. So I wish
you the best of luck. And the RHANTs,
take it away.
Alright.
So I think the first thing that we
thought of since we know that this was
intentionally broken, let's have a quick look if
there's some hints that we have left in
the bash history.
Yeah. Looks like
that was deleted.
I guess it's not your first one. Too
bad. Too bad. I will tell you, I
actually forgot to delete it until the tech
check when one of my colleagues, Laura, actually
said, did you delete the history? I was
like, yeah. I did. And then I didn't.
And then I so thanks, Laura.
Alright.
That was just the
first thing we were gonna check. So
I guess
let's try
getting the kube config and
see if we can do anything
with the cluster at all.
I I it's probably completely broken as that's
the point of this, but
let's see.
I think it's in, like what was it?
I see Kubernetes or something.
Yeah. That's right. The admin dot conf is
the failure. Conf. Yeah.
Do we are we supposed to just to
just do commands
from
this node? Or Yeah. Just just work from
this node. That way the audience can follow
along. Yeah. That makes sense. So I guess
let's just start with You'll need to export
KubeConfig equals that file. Ah, right.
Okay.
Alright. Well I can see something. Doesn't
the control plane isn't entirely broken. That's something.
Let's
see. Can you do a all all namespaces?
Uh-huh. Or I can actually
yeah. That's fine.
Nice.
Okay.
So I would encourage you when you're executing
commands to use a pager rather than scrolling
on your site, again, just so the audience
can follow along.
Yeah. Just just when you're introspecting.
So you're saying this one, the audience can't
see very well? Oh, they can. But if
you're looking at logs or do not describe,
if you type it through less, it means
they can follow your cursor.
Got it. Got it.
Alright. So
looks like
looks like it's just the the app that's
currently in crash loop back off.
Something interesting as we were kind of breaking
our cluster that we were thinking through also
is that it's it could be interesting to
have a look at what
when the when the pods were last restarted
so we know, you know, what might have
potentially been messed with.
Yeah. So could be interesting. We can see
that the what is it?
API server has been restarted
somewhat recently.
Ingress
agent.
Was there even an Ingress
on our cluster? I don't remember there being
one. The cluster, shipped with the service.
There's just a note part that you can
access. Right? So
Yeah. We just use the node part. The
the ingress, even if it was broken, it's
not a big deal.
Got it. Anyways, there's there are a couple
of
pods that were restarted in the.
I don't even know this ingress.
Something new.
It was formerly
ambassadors ingress. I can't remember the name before.
I I think it was just ambassador ingress.
Yeah. I think yeah. Yeah. I I remember
ambassador ambassador just Sounds familiar. Yeah.
Yeah.
Alright.
I guess then let's have a look at
events and see why this thing is crash
looping.
Events.
Incorrect.
Very funny, Russell. But, no, I am not
cheating and using my admin privileges.
Alright. So
looks like it's the
container
that's
failed, and let's have a quick look at
if we can see more in the pod
status.
Autocomplete work with this thing?
You can I I don't think it works
with the with the names of the part?
Yeah. We do, like, copy it. We can
enable the autocomplete if you want. I can
give you the command for that.
Oh, that would be nice. Yeah.
Okay.
So that just went totally out of my
pain. Someone else can take over because
Let me load the auto complete party.
Control.
Is shell all complete or just all complete?
We'll find out.
Oh, I can't even type. That's the camera
curse.
I swear I've done this before.
Oh, completion.
We'll get there.
So so this command of kubectl will just
return a batch script that you source?
Yeah. Never do this. Now now you can
tap complete for your partners. Right.
I think it's been, like, four years since
I set auto completion up, so I don't
even know how to do it anymore.
There go I, Bartlett.
Yeah.
So what were you're saying you wanna, like,
look at the the part
and then
type that to less.
And
or did you describe the part, Frederick?
I I just did
dash o, yeah, Moe. I'm not sure exactly
why, but the moment I did that,
kind of the
the teleport session got kind of messed up
in my browser.
Okay. I think it's okay to just rejoin
it, right, since it's just an
since I'm not the You can. It's because
it tried to resize the to everyone's screen.
So, normally, you get a scroll within a
scroll, but you you should still be able
to move the scroll bar at least. It
just sometimes feels a a bit weird.
I can't scroll in having it opened unless,
though. So
what you were saying, like That's okay. I'll
I'll just scroll. Okay. You can scroll like
that. Okay.
So
so, yeah, it's it's running.
It just terminates with with an exit code
of zero.
I don't know. Something about the volume I
just saw.
Yeah. The volume contains injected data from multiple
sources.
K. Interesting. I don't think I've seen this
one before in real life anywhere.
So
the mounts mount
a
service account,
and there are where are the volume mounts?
They just called that. Yeah. They just called
that. Right?
But I guess further down, there's the cube
API access
volume.
That's maybe
it's, like, hard to read the YAML in
this, like, different format, so I usually like
to
just return it as YAML.
Maybe you can scroll scroll like this.
It's a bit easier. At least it's, like,
more similar to what you would usually type.
Right?
So why is the pod crashing?
Yeah. I'm not seeing
the volume. We can put we can have
a look at logs. We don't yeah. Definitely.
I would run it this crave again.
But, Frederic, do you actually remember what we
said? We wanted to just deploy Key Prometheus,
and I think the
control plane works so far. So we can
just, like, deploy
the monitoring stick and see what's up.
We
can. We can.
But, I mean, we can also, like, quickly
look at the logs first and then take
The application has no logging.
Okay. Yeah. That's why I saw But I
would rather describe again. I think you missed
you missed something. Yeah. Nothing.
Yeah. There's Okay. Then let's have a look
at describe again, TS.
Yeah. I think it's still there if you
just scroll up. Right? In the describe, we
missed something or in the. Yeah. In the
describe.
Right.
Is that fine if I clean the screen?
Yep.
Yeah. That's fine.
Actually,
there. Readiness probe failed. HTTP
probe failed with status code 404.
Are we even running the right
image,
like, of version one of this thing?
Would be good to compare with the cluster
we have.
I I mean,
I'm happy to answer questions if you wanna
validate
or verify the thing. So feel free to
edit it. I already put the
GitHub
repository,
and it's GCRGHCRAORawDashAcademySlashClusterV1.
Correct.
So
That that looks right. That looks right. Yeah.
Yep. That is the correct image.
Or 8080.
That looks right. Think that was correct as
well. Yeah.
From having read the source and work with
this
the last twenty four hours. Yeah. Like, in
the source code, I can see 88 is
what it tries to bind to.
Yeah. That I remember that port also from
the service. So Mhmm.
You missed one important piece of information than
the header.
It feels like I'm starstruck and, like, I
have to concentrate on the thing. Usually, this
should be easy. Right? Like, now I'm, like,
looking the status code 404. What does that
tell us?
Well, that the request is definitely being made,
but that that our application is not returning
what it should There is no there is
no health z endpoint on that application.
That's right. There. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't I bet it's just called
health. Yeah.
So that's a good one.
That's that's a really good one. So,
Nice try.
So I guess, should we just fix it
using cube? How to edit? Or Yeah. Just
just edit. Like, do the the fastest way
possible is the best way.
This doesn't production.
Deployment.
Clustered.
And then
that's it.
Oh,
I think that broke on on the
stream with Yeah. The CLI can't handle them
very well. I switched over to the browser
for that. I just deleted
the z at at the path of health.
Nice.
That's it. Then
maybe we can actually
get part and then watch
what happens.
It's
still not coming up though.
Yeah. You're laughing like you're giving yourself away.
I mean, let's have a look at I
just like it when because, like, when you
make the break, sometimes you're really worried that
it's just not gonna work. And I'm
very happy that it worked.
I'm I'm definitely worried about one of ours
as well, but let's get to that later.
Alright.
Let's
let's have a look at the,
like, the status of the pod one more
time then.
Mhmm.
Do you wanna take over again?
I can.
Describe pod, I guess.
Ah, whoops. Yeah.
That's
oh, my god. Can't even type.
Alright. So
It's still saying
no. That's old.
Now it's the fails to start, I guess.
Right? Yeah. That that always throws me off
still. I think
the probe failing was, like, last seen
seven minutes ago now,
was it? Yeah.
It still says health zed in the description
though with the readiness
and liveness probe. Yeah. So Can you run
we update everything. Can you run get close
again?
Right. So
Yeah. This part hasn't even been updated. Yeah.
So what happens when you modify the deployment?
There's, like, a controller that needs to kick
in to take over in on the scheduler.
Right?
But
it isn't reconciled. Like, if we look at
can we describe the
the
it's called the replica set?
Yeah. I mean, we've got the
I mean, I'm I'm guessing the replica set
is not
updated. Right? Right. The replica set is not
updated. Help zed.
Well, no. They created. The new one gets
created.
Right. And that hasn't happened.
Yep.
At least the the replica set that is
there
does not have
the the modification, which means
that probably the it hasn't been updated.
Laura said in chat that there's a hint
if we need one. Thank you, Laura.
Maybe you should read the hints.
No. Yous are yous are on the right
path. Yous are talking about it. Yous are
describing
how this works. Oh, yeah. It's super valuable
to everyone watching. So you you know that.
You definitely know that.
So so I can we can we check
cube system?
Yeah. I I I would check the cube
system namespace for,
like,
the controllers being up and and reconciling our
stuff
probably are the webhooks. I
But I think Russell is suggesting that I
could have used a mutation commission controller.
But yeah.
Actually the controller manager. Yeah.
The controller manager is there.
We were thinking of deploying a a faulty,
like, admission webhook that would,
like, deny every creator or something like that.
So Seems like we aren't the only ones.
Maybe we're not the only ones.
User user on the right path. Don't go
down the webhook path. That's that's
Russell is
very smart, but incorrect on this occasion. User
user already on the right path for your
conversation.
So first thing that I can already see
actually so there's also a readiness probe that
is also pointed at health health z. So
that will also be a problem later.
Mhmm. But maybe we wanna fix that
already just so so
Yep.
Yeah. So I did miss one. Yes.
I
love how the livestream
is just completely broken when using Vim. Yeah.
I have to Hey. Yeah. Switch it over.
I I still have Vimium on. Can you
hit escape for me, Matthias?
Yep.
There you go. Thank you.
That was also the control c bug with
teleport was very fun, wasn't it?
Yeah.
Yep.
But there's, like, Vimception for you, Frederic. Like,
you have the Vim in the
in the cluster and then the Vimeo in
the browser.
Yes.
How to exit two layered Vims.
Alright. So
what did we say? Admission webhooks. Right?
No. We wrote that. Controllers.
Ah, we It's all the controller. Yeah.
Yeah. Let's look at the controller manager then,
I would say. Alright.
Okay. You wanna look at logs, or what
do you wanna look at?
That's Is it the controller manager or the
this or the scheduler, though?
Well, the,
no, the the controller manager has the deployments
controller
Right. Exactly. Yeah. Should be the thing that
creates the new replica set. So we can
have a look at the logs of the
controller manager.
No. What I love about this is that
you both know Kubernetes absolutely inside out, but
it shows how easy it is or how
difficult it is to debug problems, right, in
production even when you know that. For sure.
We can we can definitely see here
leader election,
error retrieving resource lock,
kubectl
kubesystem
controller manager.
It
it's getting
connection refused.
Alright. So
I think we were talking about firewall rules
at some point.
So maybe we've got something
nasty there. So what is it?
That was yeah. That's inactive. That's
inactive. Alright.
So that's one.
Gosh. I don't remember.
What is it? IP table. It's flush or
something. Dash capital l for less, and you
can do dash capital f to flush.
You know this too quickly. I think you've
done that.
Like this you said? Or Oh, that you've
so you've just done the flush. So all
the IP tables rules will be rewritten by
a zillion. And then if the failures Now
we can
dash dash list rules.
Or just capital l. We'll list them. Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. Okay.
So there is no firewall in play.
Okay.
Or I just flush everything.
Let let's have another look at those logs
then.
How familiar are you with cube admin clusters?
Haven't haven't used those in a while.
We're
using GKE for everything now.
My camera is overheating.
As long as we can hear you, that's
fine, I guess. I was I was pushing
that. We know you're still there. My backup.
Right.
Yeah. No. It's it's been a while since
I used q a d m as well.
I think even, like, back at,
not Kubamatic,
they used this, I think, beneath the,
like,
the other schedulers
they had.
I mean,
connect connection refused.
Can we are are we even sure that
this is the right
address
that it's going to connect to?
Like, I I remember when I was looking
at our
Hoop API server, there was some other address.
It was, like, 6443
or something like that.
I mean, we can just look at the
service Kubernetes in the default namespace. Right? That
should probably tell us. Do do you wanna
take over again? For some reason, some some
resizing happened again for me. And Yeah. I'll
just clean the Okay. Yeah. The screen, and
then it should be fine for everybody. So
the service like this, there's, like, default
Kubernetes service in every Kubernetes cluster that always
has, like,
a IP to the API server.
So that is ten nine six zero one.
I think that was, like, something with a
five in the logs. Right?
That's
completely different.
Yeah. So the service is the internal cluster
IP for the control. Mhmm.
The the this
yeah. But what we just saw was
that
the
actual
like, the the the the service just forwards
to something somewhere else. Right? And that
uses some different port, I think.
You're using an admin.com
to speak to this cluster. Right?
Do you remember where where that lives? Yeah.
Matthias, can you can you have a quick
look at the address that's in there?
The oh, the con?
Is it is it fine to just show
this?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's I'm asking you again.
No. You feel you could you could flash
that. Yeah. That's that's okay. Right.
Now you have to be quick typing, or
I can at least let me
grab something. So so
it it seems like this address is just
completely wrong.
Like, it's it's neither the internal one, and
I don't think you even use the internal
address
for for the setup. So let's just try
to modify the
the address that it's trying to connect to
to this one.
So
I'm guessing
let's look at the deployment
of
that thing. It might be a
I I don't think it's a it's a
deployment. I no. I it might even be
a static pod.
It
is. A static pod. Yeah.
Yeah. Patrick.
No. You can't you can't modify those. They're
on disk somewhere. I I forget exactly where.
But Right. But I should be able to
get the Yes. You can get the pod,
definitely. The pod. Right?
So that's called controller,
the cube controller manager. Yeah. Cube controller. Thank
thank you a thousand times for setting up
the auto completion earlier.
Yeah. I don't I don't know how to
to work
otherwise.
Okay. So
lots of text.
Yeah. It should be further up.
Yeah. Where there the commands in the flex
are, I would say.
Mhmm.
K. So it uses a cube config that
is the controller
manager account.
So maybe if we look
at that one and compare it with the
app admin one.
Yep.
It is too easy for you, Frederick.
So something like that. Wanna pick that for
less just for the Yeah. Let me
well, just correct server.
So one is
different than the other.
So which one is correct? I would say
the admin one is correct. Well, there's there's
a bunch of .coms and slash Etsy Kubernetes.
Just I actually I I just wanted to
point out something since people
might be confused why hasn't spoken up.
His Internet
is entirely broken. And Who knows?
Yeah. His his ISP is a % offline.
So Alright. No worry. Unfortunately,
he
he can't be here right now.
But we had three replicas.
Oh gosh.
I
mean, let's
Let's compare with the scheduler one then.
Right?
Or cube
Kubelet.
Yeah. So that's that's this one. This can
be a lot of users.
I wanted to compare
these two.
So there is the
controller manager.
It's just Kubernetes.
You didn't you forgot an s.
Such a
Sometimes I forget. I like to quit them,
and I I delete words. You know? It's
it's it's an accident.
Yeah. That makes makes a lot of sense.
That happens
in production.
Too bad.
I I I love Unix tools like this.
It makes it so much easier.
So,
yeah, let's
edit the
controller manager at that part.
6443.
That's the only instance.
Hold on. Frederic, do do you know how
to restart
the pod?
Do we need to do this?
You will have to delete the pod. Yeah.
You you should be able to just do
delete pod.
And then it will be I think
if I remember correctly, the way that the
static pods work is that even if you
delete them, if they are present in that
wherever on disk, they will be recreated all
the time. That is correct. I think the
kubelet will will
rematerialize
them.
They said there was, like, a checkpoint for
Kubernetes at some point,
but I think that's slightly different still. Right?
That's just Yep. The kubelet Yeah. So what
you I think what you're remembering is BootKube.
And BootKube
used
used checkpointing
used static parts to checkpoint
things like etcd.
If people still remember Bootkoop,
that was, like, self hosted Kubernetes
where we used at CoreOS, we used Kubernetes
to spin up Kubernetes,
and you needed, like, a bootstrapping cluster,
and checkpointing was kind of a
snapshot of a point in time. And then
it was
well, it kind of pivoted from static pods
to,
quote, unquote,
real pods.
It was it was fun.
So what I loved about that break is
that at no point does the controller manager
ever say that it's not ready or healthy
even though it can't Yeah. Speak to the
to the APIs server.
There you go.
Alright. The controller manager was restarted,
but I don't think
the
replica set was updated. Right?
Well As it looks.
Let's let's see if we progressed in any
way.
Okay. So that looks like it's still only
one. Let's have a look at the logs
of the controller manager again. That's what we
tried to fix. Right?
Yep.
That'll
be the old one.
Oh, no. Wait. Did you do logs on
the actual part, or did you do it
from the
Yeah. On the on the part. Right? Yeah.
Let's actually tell this.
I'm actually confused. That's still the wrong port.
Yeah. Like, it's not the updated port.
Yep.
So
we
we look at no.
But the
the part
not delete the part.
Describe.
Yes. Describe the
controller manager part. And if we scroll up,
we see that we
were using the controller manager,
though. So that's the one we updated.
Is there
any other place?
Like, the bind address looks somewhat
suspicious to me. Like, that
that's, like, an easy thing to
to modify this way.
But why would the
the controller manager just talks to the
Right. Kubernetes API even if it were to
bind to the wrong address?
Did you update the port correctly and the
controller manager Yeah. I was I was gonna
say that as well. Just double check that
we actually
Yeah. There's no difference
between those two
when it comes to server, at least.
So, I mean, the admin conflict will be
different, I suppose. Oh, yeah. You did put
it right.
So the control element, 10721415,
and
we grab
find access here.
You wanna have a look at the Mhmm.
Do you wanna have a look at the
whole config
just real quick?
Yep.
I mean, you can
take over as well if you want to.
Someone from the from the audience said that
I think
coup the Kubelet doesn't restart static pods If
you delete it using kubectl, either restart couplet
or restart controller manager
pod using
c r I c r I c t.
Yeah.
I just I'm gonna make sure that I
don't leave an old break in that I
did remove. I'm I'm just gonna
Open to here.
I think my screen is doing a weird
thing there.
Yeah. That's what we Charlie just said, isn't
it? An Etsy Kubernetes
manifests. Yeah. That's what we actually just opened
here. Yeah. Okay. So that's the thing we
we need to
to modify. That's where those that's where the
static pods are. I I don't think we
need to modify anything in here.
Alright.
Because we modified
the Someone else Yeah. Someone else in the
audience said that we might need to restart
the in
order to have it have it take effect.
I don't remember that. But
Yeah. I think using Vem on that fail
has restarted the controller manager now.
You're using what? Sorry. It appears to have
restarted the controller manager now.
Ah, maybe Just by giving it time.
There you go.
Yeah. Go go back to your get replica
set command, and then you should do something
different.
They sent me ten seconds ago.
Alright. Alright.
So it's there now.
It
seems like it's up and running.
Yeah. Let's check the
check the size
Cluster.
I guess it's yeah.
Let me
You can curl. We'll do those 30,000 if
you want to test that. Yeah. Okay. That
also works.
Yeah. I can
I saw that one coming?
Yeah. The database connection doesn't work.
You
have five minutes left.
For the database connect to work.
So
right. I I take a look at our
our doc
real quick to copy some
commands
for the database maybe.
So let's say we have
we have
Postgres running.
Actually, can we have a quick look at
the error message that we saw there?
Because the can you do the curl one
more time?
Error connecting to server failed to look up
address information name or service
not known.
That like, let's first make sure that the
Yeah.
Service for the Postgres
is even there.
True.
Yeah. Good point.
Do you wanna type, or do you want
me to Yeah. Go
ahead. Start with typing.
So Postgres there,
and then if we say Postgres and look
at it's Yammer.
You can see, yeah, 5432
is the port. Do you see something already?
No. No. I was just saying, is that
is that the right part? Is that the
Postgres part? I'm not sure. Yeah. That's it's
always, like, five and then counted backwards,
like, increasing.
That's how I remember it.
Would have broken penis, would he? Yeah.
So,
again, copying our commands.
Let's see what do we have here. Let's
look at.
Or do you wanna do you wanna try
I mean, yeah, is definitely That looks fine.
Yeah.
I was gonna say, try let's try to
exec into the clustered pod and Mhmm.
Like,
try to connect to the Postgres
database from there.
Right.
I should even have
command ready.
Came prepared.
However,
problem wise is or the problem is that
there is no drill or dig in this
container.
You can have to update and that install
DNS dash utils if you want dig. Oh,
there. See, I didn't even realize that earlier.
Yeah. So it was, like, some distro less
or some You have to add up space.
There
was, like, some super small container that didn't
have a package manager. So
I'm I'm surprised there's app in here. I
didn't even try it earlier.
That was me being very nice to people
that come on the show.
Yep.
I think, yeah, now it broke on my
side. I can't
really see what I'm typing. Can I type
clear? Ah, that worked.
Now it's broken for the stream, though. I
reset
Okay.
Yeah. So install
oops. They're called big or DNS.
Rick just mentioned
DNS,
Then I need to be able to type
install
DNS details.
Yes.
I'm just a Arch Linux boy.
I'm going going
to Which shell did you run? This is
a bash. I think that's why you're having
so many Yeah. It's
If you run bash It's like the
adjust bash. Yeah. There you go. That'll work
better.
So now there is
oh, there is
yes.
K. That doesn't work.
I just read the
read the livestream.
So we're see Postgres
because that's the host that, like, connects to.
That's, like, baked into the application in the
source code I saw earlier. It is. Yep.
Do you wanna, like, just Telnet
the
address import?
Probably, there is no Telnet yet.
Post.
Dang.
Yep.
Yeah. I I mean, we don't get, like,
a proper DNS response back on top. Right?
Like, there's no
IP address
in
in in this.
Yep. And you're all out of time. So
close. Too mad. Too bad. Like, I I
bet something in in core DNS.
But I I didn't touch core
DNS. Oh, you're still in the container. Yeah.
In the container. So I went to the.
And
if we Giving
it a different
sorry. My terminal is really weird. Let's just
do this. Messed up the, like, cluster DNS
or what? Yeah.
Yeah.
So that
cluster's
IP address where the DNS lives is a
different one than it actually is?
It's not the kubel. Oh, where the hell
did I change that?
Kubernetes manifest.
Yeah.
No.
The kubecta service.
Where did I change it?
Web API.
Where is that?
No. It's definitely in the Kubik Con. Oh,
I changed it on the worker nodes. Oh,
that's fine.
Oh. Even
on the worker notes.
If we
pop over here and go to
Lumi worker one
and I modify bar
lib kubect config dot YAML.
Yeah. The cluster domain was changed here from
cluster dot local to Kubernetes.local.
Oh. Yeah. Okay. But that breaks because, like,
the application is just looking for Postgres as
a host name. So I'm surprised it it
breaks
it breaks the hardware.
End dots to fill in the rest of
the domain as Kubernetes.local.
So by the end, I guess, the core
DNS. There's there's never anything. And then there
was one really horrible thing at the end
where you wouldn't have been able to pull
the container image anyway because I stuck container
d in the freezer c group. So
Particularly harsh, but you started awesome there. It's
like there there there was a lot to
unpack there, and I love the fact that
you were sharing,
you know, history and knowledge as you went
along. So
I wonder how long it would have taken
to get to the other two now. But
those I mean, the DNS one seems doable,
but the
that other that other one, that seems pretty
pretty rough to be fair. Yeah. I I
would I would love that you sit on
that one for too long. So but good
job. Now
did I ask? Thank you. How is
how is Cluster 2?
Yeah. So, I mean, I was driving this,
but I can quickly,
in, two minutes
I'm gonna check if Cluster 1 magically came
back. Yeah. I I tried in between. Alright.
But
it's it's gone. But let's reload.
I don't know what happened on that one,
really.
It's just completely
disappeared.
Alright. Well,
I well, say thank you very much and
goodbye to you just now. If you could
break your cluster in the background and we
will do our introductions for as long as
possible.
And if you can give us a nod
in the comments, that would be wonderful. But
thank you, Frederic. Thank you, Matthias.
Great job. I'll see you, Boston. Thanks. Thanks
for having us. Cheers. Thank you.
Alrighty.
Let team make up.
Up. Put my camera over here. Do need
to update everything over to my other camera?
Alright. Pulumi team, please join if you're still
watching. I see that we've got one so
far.
Hey, Steve.
Hey. How's it going? How's it going?
It's it's getting there. Although, now as I
move this on to the next one, I'm
gonna there we go.
Hey, Laura.
Hello.
Hello?
Can you hear me? Yeah. We can hear
you. You're all good. All good. Yeah.
We're just waiting on one more.
And what the how was that? Did she
just have fun watching that?
It's a little intimidating.
Just a little.
No. That was great. They did a great
job finding, you know, getting down to it.
When you know when you know the when
you know the answer, you could see them
just scooting on the edge, you know. So
it was great. Yeah. That a good a
good debug there.
Russell and the audience is asking, and I
will show my final break.
I mean, I guess we've got a minute
so we can do.
I'll pop back over to the screen share.
Jump on to
one of these nodes.
So there was a mystery service
called Teleport Proxy
running on this,
which was running a script
called Teleport Proxy,
which was trained on the pet of container
d and
freezing it every one second.
Yeah.
Maybe too harsh though. I did start I
did freeze the cupola as well and and
prior to just going live,
but there were far too many error messages.
The whole system was falling over,
and I saw it make it easier.
Alright. When we have our whole team, we're
just gonna wait for someone from Polar Signos
to give us a note in the comments.
But let's start with some introductions.
And, Steve, if you wanna kick that off
and we'll work around clockwise, that would be
great.
Sure. So, everyone, I'm Steve Sloca.
I'm a staff software engineer here at Pulumi.
I just joined, like, a month or so
ago.
I came here from VMware through Heptio. So
I used to work at Heptio, and I'm
a maintainer on Contour.
So if if you're off my with ingress
controllers, Contour is an ingress controller for Kubernetes.
Awesome. Thank you. That's that's my story. I
work on the this this SaaS product for
Pulumi is what I do here. Nice. I
didn't know you worked on Contour. That's what
I use on my own production infrastructure. It's
such a cool one. There you go. So
let me know. Yeah. Then whenever I get
a bug, I'm gonna be hitting you up
on the Slack. But, hey, man. Yeah. What
what's the problem here?
Yeah. For sure.
Alright. Vivek?
Sure. My name is Vivek.
I am a engineer here with Voomi. I've
been here for a little over a year
and a half, I think.
Yeah. And I primarily work on the provider's
team,
specifically
spend a bunch of time
sort of taking care of the Kubernetes
aspects of Gloomy.
Yeah.
That's me. Spend a little bit time before
that
running some large scale production Kubernetes clusters.
Yeah.
I'll leave it there for now. Awesome. Thanks.
And Laura?
My name is Laura Santa Maria. I'm a
developer advocate here at Pulumi,
and I come here from all over the
place. I but I am on
SIG contributor experience in upstream Kubernetes.
And
my
biggest claim to fame with all of this
is that I used to run an entire
cluster
before Kubernetes of Docker within Docker.
So all of my horrible horrible experiences
there hopefully will help here.
We'll find out.
Well, I have no idea what polar signals
have in store for us. But the fact
that I completely trashed their first cluster does
leave me a little bit concerned
and worried.
And you left a few ideas in your
in their mouth and
I'm a little worried they're in here, like,
breaking it again.
Now I'm just wondering, like, what are they
gonna add to all of this?
Okay.
So he's gonna leave out the bet that
properly trashed it. I think that's a good
idea. I
don't wanna have to be fixing this with
any more of a timer than we already
have. So Yeah. We just give
PS another minute or two.
Sounds fair. I love that they're not even
sure. They think they're leaving out. I
mean, these are They should be pretty beefy
boxes. Like,
I don't know what they've done. The fact
that SSH like, you could ping the box.
It was online with an IP address, but
SSH was just 100%
not responsive.
We'll wait to wait and see.
Alright. Matthias has said thirty seconds.
I have to share what they did after
we're done to see, you know
curious what they did to break it. Yeah.
All the breakers notes are available on github.com/rocketacademy/custard,
where we will put the Bologna bricks as
well.
Okay.
Spoilers as they're not doing it. There it
You used firewall to block SCD. Like, nobody
gets firewall rules right the first time.
So clearly, you've just you've blocked everything.
That's
that's been our problem. Alright.
Matthias, can I connect? In fact, know what?
I'm connecting. You've had plenty of time. So,
I'll share my share my screen.
And I am going to open a session
on control plane two. Matthias has given me
a yes now as well, so perfect.
That's because
it's my fault. That is not them.
Alright.
We have an echo hi from me. If
you could please go to active session activity
and active sessions, go to the bottom and
join and just give me an echo to
let me know that you're in the session.
We will get this kicked off.
Well, that's fun. I'm getting an access denied.
Oh, yeah. I didn't give you access.
I was wondering what I was doing wrong.
I will modify the Pilbara team now and
let you actually take part in the show.
So
Sorry. My my brain is just frazzled today.
There we go. You're good. It's You're you're
good, highly entertained thinking that they had already
broken that
so that they made it so that only
you were allowed in.
Oh, okay. Try again. You should be alright.
Alright.
Oh, Matthias was worried that it broke it.
Nope. It was just me. All good.
Fireball rule was only saying that bash would
have been helpful. Alright.
Steve, Vivek, you just end the session?
I'm coming. I forgot the link. Here we
go.
It was like I I was on worker
one and I was like, why isn't this
working? Someone's in result.
Whatever.
I just had to look at it at
my browser too in case we need to
switch to Vim, which of course we will.
So
Right. Anyone feeling particularly interested in
driving?
Sorry, Vivek. I left you off the screen
there. Sorry about that. No. You're good. It's
fine. Alright. Pretty good, but I will I
know it's all all weird on my side.
I don't know.
Alright. Well, I'll handle the taping and just
Sounds good. Communicate.
Tell me what to do. So I have
set up our cube config and go straight
into the alias and
run You can get your alias. Okay.
We have a control plan.
Didn't seem to be it. Let's the pod.
Actually working. I'm now very nervous.
Well,
we don't have a clustered pod.
Yep.
But we do have
posters
at least.
Alright. What do just wanna check next?
So we don't have the pod. Do you
wanna take a look and see if maybe
there's a deployment for the thing at all?
Or
There is. Cluster deployment?
Okay. Should we edit?
Yeah. Let's just go straight in.
Yes. Yeah. Why not? We're gonna have fun.
Let's do it. Alright.
Alright. What are we looking for in here,
team?
So
this thing exists. Let's can you go down,
like, I guess?
Let's see what the template looks like.
Yeah. Request for your v one.
Blah blah blah.
I mean, I'm
gonna guess
so there is no pod. I'm guessing there
isn't a replica set either.
I was gonna say right now, it says
replicas are zero.
So
Oh, yeah. Oh, hey. You good good catch.
Yes.
I mean, maybe we should start there.
Good good catch, Lauren. That's a good one.
I don't know if that's gonna just get
it. Oh, no. It is ready. Okay.
Well,
it's not done anything. So
I know. But, I mean, like, at least
now, it's it's it's closer.
It's not, like, crashing
completely.
So let's
go back. Yeah.
Oh, replica is back to zero.
Alright. Nice effect.
What are we thinking?
Interesting. I mean, I can set this to
one again, but I'm pretty confident.
So what's the revision
on that view? I mean, one might also
wanna take a look at what's going on
on the revision on that.
Yep. So So generation
six
sorry. One more edit. Why not?
Let's see what happens.
Generation eight? Eight? Oh, that's interesting. Some big
changes.
Sorry. I was gonna use the wrong word
there.
Some sort of a mutate a webhook or
something, I think.
I should really load it up quickly.
I am really impressed that you can type
all that.
I am gonna load out a complete just
now. But, yeah, there's no mutation admission controller.
Okay. But that was my first part too.
Yeah.
Interesting.
So something's
going around changing in.
Yeah. That's crazy. I first thought I first
thought was the selectors matched the labels,
y'all went down a different path, which makes
sense.
Well, the generation doing that
double bump.
Yeah. That was the thing that's, like, kind
of interesting.
Should we see some
events or something? Or It's a good comment
from Russell, actually. Like, if this was a
new station admission controller,
it would have been a single generation bump
rather than two. So something external. Got it.
Right. Probably.
Messing with this.
I I gotta ask. There's like there's no
way someone else could be connected to this
modifying it live. Right?
Like, just making sure because
that could always happen. I mean, I'm sure
Matthias is a very quick typer but I
mean, those editors were fast. Really fast.
Yeah.
Can we run top
on this?
Just to see what's running in case there's
something else running?
No.
Okay.
I mean
Okay. They just they just said no. It's
all inside the cluster.
Okay.
I
mean, I I've got a hypothesis, but I'm
I'm gonna hold off because it's on the
the way of things.
Are there are there any other pods? Like,
if you say get get pods all
across the cluster to see what else is
there.
Control.
So the age
strikes me as suspicious.
Yeah. I I was looking at that VIP
Damon's. Is that Damon's set? Yeah. Could be
third
third one from the top.
For BGP advertisement.
So that is
well, I mean, don't know if they've modified
it, but it's certainly
I am happy that it's there in the
cluster.
The thing I'm not happy about, just because
I know the code, is metric server. I
don't think cluster has ever had a metric
server before.
Well,
then why don't we go see what said
metrics cluster is doing?
What is said metrics cluster?
I mean, they wouldn't give a a a
safe name and then lie to us, would
they?
Why not? Why not? It'd be fine.
Why is that not all of the TV?
The first thing that caught my eye. Yeah.
Nice.
So can we just like wipe this thing
off?
Just to see what it does?
Yeah?
You
don't you don't want to look at it
anymore. You just want to disappear. Is that
what you're Well, no. I like I don't
know. This is my version of debugging. Like,
if it's something that I don't know what
it is, it goes away.
So
we can, like, just disable it and try
to turn it off. We're gonna see what
it does.
See it. It's gone.
Alright. So
then what's We will never know what it
takes. Modify things.
Alright. Oh, somebody's got a good question if
there's any cron jobs running, which that makes
sense. That's
fair.
And there are no.
Yay. Okay.
You just wanna try to edit again?
Yeah. Let's do it. Let's try it. What
did it do? What will it do? Now
we were at eight. Right? So that was
the version we were at?
Are we still at eight? Yeah. Good.
That's a good sign.
Hey.
That sounds right. Hey. Hey. It's keeping it.
It's keeping it. Nice. Good job.
That's a good point.
We
have a pod.
Nice.
Let's It's a start. Curl back. K.
Yes. And
and to answer the chat, yes, I randomly
will delete things that don't look familiar. So
it was my cluster. I know what's supposed
to be there. So
Yep.
Should we try curling and see what happens?
Yeah. I think I think I think be
here.
Uh-oh.
Database is not currently accepting connections.
Okay.
So
let's take a look at the the
the spec again and see what the, I
guess, the Postgres
connection string is, I guess. I don't remember
if that's how it works. I'm assuming there's
a connection string somewhere in the spec. It
is hard coded into the Rust application as
Postgres.
Gotcha. Okay.
Database clustered
is not accepting currently accepting connections. Did they,
like
it sounds like it's actually establishing connection.
It's like the actual database
might have
basically some
it's, like,
disabled connections.
So do we need to, like, pop into
Postgres potentially?
I hope not.
The Steve is so so
well versed now with all of this. I'm
curious if what do you think?
It's apparently, Matias is saying that that
Lokitus. I'm not sure if that's how you
pronounce it. Is that JSON or JSON or
however you wanna pronounce that base controller that
was set in a replica zero.
Lokitas of Borg. Very nice. Very nice. Lokitas?
Is that how you would say that? I'm
assuming I'm assuming it's Lokitas of Borg. I'm
assuming that's what it refers to. Alright. Okay.
Because Star Trek.
But that's where my brain goes. I only
watched Star Gate. I've never seen Star Trek
ever.
Oh, David. We have to fix that.
Anyway,
so
Is the is the Postgres service called clustered?
Is that what we're supposed to connect to?
Yes. Our service is there. It's called Postgres.
And it's port eighty eighty?
Or no? That's the web application.
That's the web app? That's the web app.
Five four three two is the Postgres.
So
What if you describe that Postgres? Does it
select the pod?
It has an endpoint which Okay. And it's
5432 is that matches.
So Fredrik, it's not that I don't like
Star Trek. It's that I grew up on
s g one and have never watched Star
Trek. Now, I'm perfectly willing
to reconcile and fix this.
Well, I I will make sure we get
we get a list. We'll we'll make a
list. Yeah. Make me a list.
Don't we do
so the endpoint is ten zero one ninety
one.
Yeah, I see an endpoint. I mean, that
I'm relatively confident that
Yeah. The selectors are are okay. Should we
do we have PC pull or something, like,
that we have that we could try connecting
to the database ourselves, perhaps?
Oh, we can exec into cluster.
Yeah. If we exec into the worker, we
might be able to, like, kinda poke at
that
into the pod. I I do believe that's
available.
Oh,
that's DNS. Okay.
Alright.
Interesting.
So So
who knows how DNS works in Kubernetes?
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess I'm just wondering.
1096010.
So that is the
hard coded IP address for Yeah.
That is sorry.
is fine and
That sounds right. Alright. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I think so.
Should we pop out and see if
is running and stuff like that? Great question.
K. I mean, it's quite fifteen minutes old.
But it it is Well, so that that
one but that one was the one that
had the lowest time since modified,
since started
among the entire thing earlier. Yeah. I spun
this customer up an hour ago. So Well,
no. It said eight minutes where everything else
was eight minutes thirty seconds. Right. That one
could have been modified after it came up
is what I'm curious about.
Should we just take a look
at the accordion access
spectrum? Yeah.
You can override that, can't you, with a
secret or something
or extended, I guess. Yes.
So
at least it's the core DNS image. I'm
I'm pretty confident this is the correct
Yeah.
Yeah. Almost another Star Trek container.
Anything
you just wanna see in here?
Volume mounts, Etsy core coordinates. Okay. So so
I might be kind of poking around because
they rolled all the pods to hide the
metric server. So that may be why
maybe it's not actually in here.
Curious if you at the config, the Etsy,
like, the actual thing. Yeah. You could take
a nap.
Lame duck.
Exactly. That's that's that's real and legit. I
I know. It's just I hope every time
I see it, I'm kinda like, wait.
Underneath Prometheus, the forward progress.
Oh, yeah?
Where where is that? I missed that on
the line. It's yeah. Oh, okay. Yeah.
Nice. Yeah. Good catch.
Let's do that.
Let's hope it.
I guess we'll It should how should I
match create?
Will it?
I think coordinates will just pick it up.
No. We're gonna find out. I I'm not
convinced, to be honest.
I mean, we can always just kill the
pods
and roll them, I guess, like
Well, what's your preferred way to roll the
pods?
Because, I mean, I know what I was
about to take, but I I don't wanna
I I Bring my bad habits.
I would I'm I'm
dirty with this. I'll probably just, like, kill
the parts.
You're not the only one. That's all I
do.
So Laura's Laura's just gonna destroy everything. Right?
She's gonna
I mean
Because half the time when you do that,
it works.
You know? Have you reboot it? Have you
turned it back on and on off and
on again? It works. I mean, sensible people
would be like, let's do a rollout and
do this nicely and I'm sorry. No. Well,
but sensible people would put it on, like,
production workloads. This is not necessarily a production
workload, so why not? Hey. This application and
cluster is very important to me.
Well, I mean, we are we already locked
it over, like, three or four times in
the twenty four hours. So
Well, I have
rolled
via the deletion method or the smash method,
core DNS.
What if we can throw it now?
We should go back in and see if
No.
Okay.
Well, that's a good point, Ash. I think
we really good eye catching the post press
forward, but we couldn't run an app update,
which is not post press. So we fixed
one thing, but not this thing we were
actually trying to fix. Yeah. Definitely. Definitely. I'm
curious if the thing
connects now in theory, like, if
maybe the the application is able to connect.
Is there anything in the Postgres pod, like
the command getting overwritten or something? Or
you can can't you swap the DNS
in the pod? You can change the
change the thing. We we could apply a
custom DNS config to,
our deployment and pass that through to the
pod. Because by default, it pulls it from
the host. Right? You can override that with
Yeah.
Per pod. Is there anything running in, is
this running Docker?
Container d. Container d. Oh,
mhmm.
I was just thinking if there's something like,
somebody modified a
the daemon
the the docker daemon. But
No. I think
there must be something else in that config
map. Right?
Yeah.
Let's go look.
Cluster of.
Looks alright.
Yeah. I'm not sure That's good. If loop,
reload, and load balance are normally there.
Like, I don't remember.
Yeah. It's been a while.
Yeah. I I'm I'm not that familiar with,
like, the
config.
I wonder if we should just, like, look
up, like, whatever the the this the the,
you know,
like, standard
thing that Cordian has
ships with and just, like, replace and go
with that. Well
Pretty sure the default is
Yeah.
So
really, they don't know happened. Here.
Customization.
I thought I would Can we actually the
the logs on the worker
and, like, tail them and see what's coming
up when we actually try to ping? Because
it makes me wonder, like, is there, like,
a a forwarding
going on, or is there, like, a did
they somehow sneak, like, a VPN in there
or something that they've, like, really messed with
everything? Like, that's the kind of thing I'm
wondering.
But, again, I'm I'm a very suspicious
admin.
Okay. So that does seem to so that's
the control plane, though. Right? We should be
trying on the worker that the thing is
running. Yeah. Control c.
Oh, no. No. No.
That's we're not just stuck watching the ping.
Could you stop it there?
No. Game over. So this is a fucking
teleport. I think really teleport.
Oh, I guess I didn't think really on
that.
Can I Oh, there's no way to like
halt processes somewhere in the page?
It's not responding to control z either.
Alright. I just open a new tab. Create
a new session? Yes. Alright.
Alright. So we all get out of the
session and Can
anyone else control see that or are we
just stuck with that? I think it's yeah.
It's not responding. I tried. It didn't work.
Okay.
I guess if I just close the tab,
I should, in theory, be out. Right? Alright.
You can join there's a new session on
your activity page.
Let's jump out to there and then regroup.
Okay.
But yeah. So if we go over to
the
The chat are all telling me to open
another session and do the p kill. Yeah.
I can tell you that's not gonna work,
and I'll I'll show you it because I
still have yeah. I still got the other
session. So
I've apparently just Oh, This one's frozen. Did
something broke? I'm sorry. I might have, like,
tried to type at the same time as
someone else or something.
No. No. No. It's completely frozen now.
I'm gonna try rejoining. Is this maybe they've
broken it again?
I I I can't get in. Every time
I try and unjoin, it gives me like
a
resolve conf error.
Oh, now I'm in. I've done a peek
of on that. We'll go back to our
first session. And now you can't type. So
this is the teleport bug that I saw
downgrade and fix. Okay.
So if I join the join the next
session and I say
I I I don't know. I hope so.
Right. Okay. We got Laura back. There we
go.
But yeah. So if we hop over to
the worker and
try pinging and
see what it does. Well, don't ping. Actually,
don't ping unless you're gonna just tell it
only do ten ten pings or something.
Yeah. Was it ping c one?
Yeah. Good. Okay.
We do have Internet on the host at
least.
We potentially fixed core DNS with the postgres
forward.
But, yeah, maybe we do need to jump
on to the worker. Can we can we
look at which worker it's gone to? Like,
that's a wide whatever on the pods and,
like, hop onto that.
That's a wide, I think, to get the
the
node, right, for the pods.
Yeah. No. I can't.
We're in our head and I
can't type.
I can't I can type. So wait. We're
we're
no. I can't type.
Can't type. Frozen again. That's okay. No. It's
frozen.
Oh, no.
What I what what are you just doing
to my server for fuller signals?
Oh, no.
Okay. We're gonna try that again.
Is there anything
weird here?
No.
Well,
I don't think I've ever actually broken a
server by trying to ping things. This
is a new one. Yeah. I I have
I I don't know what is happening right
now. So
let's
let's see. So get pods.
Oh,
you didn't do your alias?
Okay. Okay.
So I think you've got a good point
in the back. It
what what if they've messed with the workers?
Right? Can we just untaint the mastery, the
control the control nodes, and let them run
on the control nodes? And then Mhmm. I
don't know. Actually, we can That's idea.
Yeah. Because the the goal is just to
get it running. Right? I don't know how.
Yeah.
Yep. Yep. Yeah. Good idea. Hammer. Hammer. Hammer.
If we'll record the card in, let's add
the Yeah.
No one said we actually had to figure
out exactly what was wrong. Just make it
work.
We can also do the other
the other smash approach, which is to come
down to spec templates.
I'd be curious the logs too at some
point. Laura, you mentioned that what the app
is actually telling us.
I mean, I guess,
I think a lot
is that me?
I don't know.
I don't know what that was. Okay.
What what what what what. What is it?
Maybe it's a back. We lost a back.
It's just everything that can go wrong is
going wrong. Alright. We have
rescheduled our workload to
our control plane assuming that they have done
something naughty to the worker node.
So why don't we exec and
We could
curl it. Right? So
okay.
So it's
database is still on the worker. Right?
True.
Should we check if we have at least
connectivity in this part and then maybe come
up with another plan?
I really need to keep that. Alright.
I'm gonna try unmuting and seeing if I'm
about to make loud noises.
No. You're okay so far.
Okay. Good. Okay. So that was a really
cool idea to card on the notes. We've
got the workload on the control plane,
but we're still
it's still DNS. So
But but I guess the database is still
running on a on a worker. Right? Yeah.
But we can't get to we can't run
an app update. So, like, we still need
to fix networking on the container on the
host either way.
And then we can maybe look at other
things.
So Well, I guess if something on that
node is stopping the connection inbound,
what's what's can you log the the app
the app and see what it tells you?
There's no I can know that the app.
There's no logging. So all you know is
that it's not currently accepting connections. Well, I
mean, we ran app update inside the container
though, and it says it can't resolve Debian.
And when we were in here, we did
cat. Why does that matter? Why does Because
there's no networking on the application.
Okay. There's no DNS resolution.
I guess we don't care about that. All
we care is that
Can the app can talk to Postgres.
Right?
I don't know what happened to my to
my machine.
Yay. But you're back.
Yeah. Well, sort of. I'm just gonna mute
myself for a bit to make sure it
doesn't happen again.
Alright. So
So we know it's DNS.
Well, we definitely have a DNS problem, but
what Steve's saying is that do we really
care if Postgres was resolved. And we don't
know if Postgres
does resolve or not.
I don't know if we have a way
to test.
Does this Postgres log anything? Can you log
that? Tell the logs in the Postgres pod.
What?
Not real. Oh, I mean custard. Oh.
Alright.
Source.
You spelled source wrong.
It's the pressure. It's getting to me. I
know.
Log of
course.
Why is it all? They're not working.
Currently not accepting connections. Oh, and then I
can't control c the terminal. Oh, wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Let's see. Oh, we can't
control c again? Nice.
Oh, no.
So okay. So
it's having any
go ahead.
I don't know what that control kubectl get
config map is
doing.
So Syntax error at error at or near
coop control at character one.
Yeah. I think the command has been overwritten
or something.
Yeah. So if we went into the
if we went into the pods spec, right,
maybe we can find out if they they
mucked with it.
Well, hang on real quick. Real quick. If
we look up a little bit, what's the
docker entry point?
Are there any
volumes attached to this?
Alright. I'll just open I'll keep opening the
session. Don't worry about joining. Okay. We can
just Yeah. We could just talk about it.
I'm gonna read backwards in the in the
logs while y'all are doing that because clearly,
that was at
Alright.
Oh, that's there. Oh, there's a guest, which
I can't.
Oh, no. I've broken that again because I
did, like, control
r.
That's a horrible teleport bug. Okay.
Here he is. Alright.
Alright. So let's add it.
SDS.
Exec is ready.
Is your what you're saying is that it'd
be the
oh, you're in the session. Cool. Okay.
Sorry. That was me in the session scrolling
up and down by accident.
Okay.
But
Will will the service forward, dude, if it's
127001?
Will that accept from outside itself?
That's just the readiness probe. Never mind. It
would, if I if I remember. Yeah. That's
just the probe. Never mind.
How about that Yeah. Config map.
It's an init config So the contact map
is how I load the data into the
post grid.
So let's take a look at that. Was
there an image here? Or it might just
be really silly. Oh, yeah. It's it's there.
Okay.
Let's check out the I'm
still kinda reading some of them. Alright. Could
the assertive be messed with? No. You're good.
Annotations.
That looks okay.
Yep. That's that's my data.
Okay.
But something else is getting called, like, looking
back at the logs themselves from the prior
the prior message.
It's saying let's see. Where am I?
Where you want me Sorry.
I might have missed some context here, but,
like, it sounded like from the Postgres logs,
we were seeing the clustered,
like, sort of it's not accepting connections thing,
and that was the message that we saw
in the in the application
as well. So
are you think there's something I'm going gonna
go back to see if maybe, like, connections
are
not enabled on the database or something. Like,
it sounded as if, like, we perhaps are
well, actually
If you do the DNS.
It was weird that it said, like, kubectl
get config map from But I wonder if
that was the teleport bug because we're gonna
end it with them, and it was mixing
the histories.
Oh. Oh. Oh, I see what you're saying.
Okay. I'm gonna go to the So Matthias
left us a a note in the chat.
You
were a little too fast deleting that line.
Postgres' problem should be orthogonal,
though. So
that line that we deleted out of the
Out of the thing?
Yeah.
But it should be orthogonal.
Okay. So
edit config map.
We delete the postgres forward.
But, I mean, that that doesn't feel like
it should be there. Right? So unless the
Right. It's completely broken.
Yeah. So in in the in the
Postgres
worker logs,
it's saying the error is syntax error at
or near kube control at character one. The
statement is kube control get
config map dash n kube system core DNS
dash o YAML all to roll postgres set
statement time at one.
So it makes me wonder,
is it sneakily
living somewhere?
It was
somewhere up. I think we're suggesting that that
may just be
Yeah. This one. The output being merged. Well,
that is that does actually look like a
locally. Right?
Yeah. Like, it it it looks like
if I didn't know better, they were trying
to put commands
into Postgres
somehow,
like, feeding the command into Postgres and, like
I don't know. I don't know. Like, it
just some something's weird about that. That's not
a command I ever see. Like, not something
I ever see in the logs for Postgres
databases.
So I'm suspicious.
Yeah.
It also says it was shut down. So
on the
right underneath the Unix socket, it says database
was shut down. So it's not even running.
So I don't can we just
Yeah. But then it came comes back up.
It was saying the database system is ready
to
Matthias is saying just copy and pasted it
wrongly. So I think that may be a
a red herring.
Oh, okay.
Still.
I'm like, something doesn't look right there. Wait
a minute.
There's no networking inside of our cust inside
of our pod. What's
in the resolve file?
On the whole oh, and the container as
I thought. Right? On the host.
Why why can't we move Postgres to the
control node?
Can't you just we can. Yeah.
Alright. I don't know if we want to
do that. So Oh, I don't know. I
was just trying to, like, get rid of
those other notes.
I don't because I I guess this we
can't exec into the web app or
to verify another container has networking, I guess.
Another pod.
Okay.
It's there now. So let's try.
And what's the log say again? What's log?
This is a time out now, actually.
Oh, it's working.
Hey.
Nice.
So wait. I I missed what you did.
What did we do?
Steve asked us to move We moved the
program.
Or was it sorry. I I can't see.
Now we can go take a look at
what the health program.
Yeah.
Alright. So now we're now we're seeing if
the
if we updated it.
We have. Great.
Nice.
Nice. Yeah. Yay.
It's, like, three and a half. We don't
know what happened. Oh, yeah. That's the idea.
I mean,
we
can we can go chase that in that
that node. So which
do you know was it like, which worker
was it at? Like, sorry. I'm kinda disoriented.
But We cart them Clearly, there's something going
on. Earlier on. Okay.
Got it.
But I I don't know if we did
have
Well, it's something that's not a good one.
Right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah. Yeah. If
Matthias or Frederic wanna
jump on and tell us what you did,
I I I would love to know more
because I have no idea
how we fixed that.
Well, while they're still jumping on,
I almost wanna, like, just hop onto the
workers and go dig around.
Well, I think restarting Postgres fixed it because
they modified Postgres.
So when we moved it
from Oh, nice. Okay.
They Gotcha.
But, like, the metrics server, first of all,
that was like I didn't expect you to
find it that quickly. That was, like, very,
very
impressive,
I have to say.
And, yeah, it just was setting replicas to
zero.
And then
the other thing I mean, we tried disconnecting
with
with the firewall
from getting a connection. Like, the API server
shouldn't be able to talk to anymore
and thus, like, basically break everything.
But, yeah, fear fearing that that would break
the entire cluster once more, we didn't wanna
go through with that. And then the other
two things, yeah, were just like DNS.
So the line you had,
and I I don't think that's still
fixed,
but I think, like, there was, like, still
state of DNS and stuff in in the
cluster
where I just set this to forward Postgres
to
the local host address.
There's usually a forward everything to
etcresolveconf
and
kind of like
that connection between and
the Etsy resolve conf, that was completely off,
and you just completely deleted that line rather
than fixing it. Right? So that's why we
could quit or that's why I can speak
to Postgres, but I can't get the NFN
external because we Yeah. Exactly. And I think
the
the Postgres was actually still working because the
service, like, the Kubernetes service that had the
correct IP address
given.
Like, it still had that in in the
in the Kubernetes object.
So maybe
there was a mistake or, like, we should
have, like, deleted that service, and then it
probably had have a a wrong IP address.
But yeah.
And then the last thing was Postgres
where you, like, correctly found out that I
was just typing copy copy pasting commands, and
then, like,
by mistake, I copy pasted a cube c
d I
command into into Postgres'
interface.
So, yeah, that that was a good one.
I had to laugh by by seeing that
when you saw that. But, yeah, in Postgres,
we
revoked select statement access
on the quotes table.
We completely disabled all the database connections for
the cluster d database.
So that's what that that was the one
you were seeing most of the time.
And then we also set all the connections
that were allowed to zero,
and the the statement time out
was one millisecond.
I think that's what just one is. So,
like, even
undoing some of the statements that were were
altering the database
wouldn't have succeeded because they would have taken
longer than one milliseconds.
Of course. To get around that by, like,
using a different user. Yeah. I went into,
like, a postcard for a.
But, I mean, you fixed it anyways. And,
yeah, congrats.
Yeah. Pleasure. Good to see you. Who
who was that that suggested moving the Postgres
onto the control plane? That was the touch
of magic.
I'm I'm deep down. I want to receive
it.
Nice. Nice.
Alright. I guess it helped that the
the break wasn't persistent for that. Right? Like,
that was the big one. So if Yeah.
I wonder if, like, modified inside.
Yes. The data coming back into the database.
It's loaded as a as part of the
edit scripts. When the container starts, it pulls
it from the content map. See.
Yeah. Every time you reschedule it, you'll fix
post quiz every single time. So Okay. Yeah.
I mean that's for their future teams. Right?
We got quite lucky there, I think. But
still,
we'll take it. Right? So Yeah. But, I
mean, like, all the other things were, like,
pretty intricate for sure.
And and it was equally impressive,
if not more than than than
what we did. And seeing people really, like,
getting into these, like, nitty gritty details is
is super fun to watch. I love the
format.
Alright. Well, thank you very much, everybody. Yeah.
That was amazing. That was really fun. I
think we got a a nice mix of
problems there and a a lot of knowledge
shared by the way that we were talking
and texting. So thank you to Polar Signals.
Thank you to my Pulumi colleagues.
Yeah. Thank you for having us. Also,
saying hi from and and Frederic once more.
Thanks for having us. It's a pleasure. Thank
you to Teleport and EquinixMetal for all their
support. See you all next week. Have a
good day. Bye. Bye. See you. Take care.
Bye.